President Biden taking a back seat and
letting one greasy-haired Governor Take
The Wheel of the democratic clown car
Grandpa Joe was supposed to be the face
of the party but lately he's been more
than happy to go to bed early and let
the young whippersnappers do all the
fighting President Biden is avoiding
press conferences like Hunter avoids
stripper babies
but the White House insists that Joe's
in control
is the administration trying to protect
the president from our questions uh
please absolutely not absolutely not
any interaction in a formal setting to
have a press conference uh I mean the
president takes shouty questions
certainly the president many times has
has Stan has stood in front of all of
you has taken questions on his own
because he wanted to see what was all on
your minds it is also unprecedented that
a president takes as many shouted
questions as this president has and
while Joe hides away California governor
Gavin Newsom is stepping up to fill the
Biden void he's been ramping up
appearances in red States and trying to
attack Republicans
I'd tell him to pack up and wait a few
years and actually do some of the hard
work which actually includes governing
not just identity and cultural work come
back as a more seasoned and capable
leader
with a little humility
which by the way he can use a little
left no I'm not running and I know it's
the perfunctory question we have to ask
anytime someone puts out a pack I get it
but I'm turned out know what else to do
with the money and this is a way of
amplifying good people all across this
country and supporting our president in
the process all right before I ask a
question that reminds me of a scene out
of the office it's where they where you
know uh
Dwight Dwight anyways trying to explain
how great they are and it's just
everybody can hear the ego talking but
Biden goes to Belfast for five days
won't take any questions I bet you're
steamed I am pretty stinged I think it's
really ridiculous and I also don't think
that for one second that the press
secretary believes that this is good
communication from the president of the
United again the president of the United
States the leader of the Free World and
he why why are the reporters shouting
questions well that's because they never
have an opportunity to actually ask him
questions and and Al broker I'm sorry
that is not going to cut it I think they
also don't want him to take questions
because they're one I think they're
afraid of what he's going to say I I've
avoided saying that up to now but I
believe that the white house that has
correctly decided that the media is
going to
give them process stories that say we
wish you would really take more
questions but they prefer to have those
negative stories than to deal with the
consequences of the stories of what he
might say on the other end and also what
happened to return to Norms I thought we
were returning to Norms the normal thing
is when a president goes overseas he
does a press conference one of the
reasons you do that is because you are
the leader of the Free World that's why
you do it and they're so they announced
yesterday they pre-announced that the
president's going away for five days to
Belfast will not take any questions from
the Press so at this point why is the
White House Press Corps going why would
you go just let the pool camera go and
don't give a starve him of attention but
the the media oh this morning on NPR
they had this report about him going to
Belfast that was so it was like oh my
gosh she's going home and it's going to
be better than John F Kennedy I couldn't
believe what I was actually hearing
because why would you pay as a news
organization to go to Belfast to sit
there for five days and to act like
State TV I think that they should should
band together and say we will starve you
of attention until you actually talk to
us I know that he's not wanting to
announce he's running for president yet
or if at all but that doesn't mean that
we don't have some serious questions
especially foreign policy questions we
are in Dire Straits at all of these
leaks what are we doing as a country I
would love to know from the president of
the United States not the White House
Press Secretary and not the White House
spokesperson for the National Security
Council what he actually thinks about
the dod leaks there are so many
questions that they could ask and
they're just absolutely giving him a
pass yeah it's funny it's like they're
on autopilot judge but I guess that's
better than having him around well
there's no question I mean if if Joe
Biden starts talking they've got to come
out and clean it up and then the
question is who's cleaning it up so it's
the smart move on their part but but I
got to tell you this Gavin Newsom
running around and he's building a
national profile and I remember it was a
couple of months ago uh he was a
stronger and this isn't a national poll
he was a stronger 2024 presidential
candidate then Kamala Harris and he is
he he was raiding very well uh in
National politics and you know for those
of us who thought oh how dare he run
these ads in Florida and go to these red
States it's it's benefiting him it's
definitely benefiting him and so uh as
he you know in spite of the fact that
think about it we came out of covid in
2022 they made fun of him at the French
Laundry he was there you know and he was
eating without a mask and he's here
without a mask and yet the people in
California love the guy the state's a
mess people are leaving California they
can barely afford it there and yet
people like him why do they like him I
don't know maybe they just like the way
he looks and he's really taking on
DeSantis which means that he believes
that santis is going to be the guy who
knows whether that's true but I find it
interesting that he says that even
DeSantis should wait you know like he
wants to run against someone like Trump
he doesn't want to run against DeSantis
but uh yeah he's a smart guy you know
with that slickback hair he is shining a
lot what do you think Geraldo are you
starting to maybe think maybe it might
not be Biden well you know I've changed
my mind in the two minutes since we
spoke on camera uh I I think uh Newsome
and DeSantis will be returned to
normalcy that'll go back to regular
politics where Trump isn't the Colossus
that alters the whole reality uh I I
think right now Trump's the only one
Trump can beat all the Republicans and
Biden's the only Democrat that can beat
Trump that's my feeling so I think that
that may be why that inertia is why
there will be abiding Trump uh redo in
terms of Gavin Newsom though and and in
a way DeSantis also although he's not
quite as Charming uh Newsome is uh glib
he's eloquent he's very handsome uh he
he's very popular in California and he's
popular with a lot of guys that I know
that have considerable resources in high
rollers that have been like him uh and
say that he's definitely the future of
the democratic party I I have no uh no
beef with with him uh nor DeSantis I
mean I don't agree with the Santa's
politics and some of the other stuff he
does in schools and so forth but I see
that he is an admirable a person who has
achieved a lot and I think Newsom will
be a good match for him and we'll get
back to Politics as normal that's an
interesting thing Jesse I don't know
Gavin newsom's track record at all like
I know California is wealthy and
beautiful and it's hard to leave that
has nothing to do with him he's not
responsible for how good that supermodel
looks he's just dating it yeah you can't
go to other Governors and tell them to
get their act together when he doesn't
have his own act together yeah I don't
know what he's done well I mean look at
California look at San Francisco we've
known the stories about crime and
Sanctuary policies Gavin Newsom is being
groomed by the Deep state to be the next
president this is what he's doing he's
going out to the entire country and he's
networking with donors he's testing out
lines he's being asked questions by NBC
Comcast oh and he has to deny that he's
considering a presidential run that's
what you do when you're considering a
presidential run so he's staying loose
in the bullpen well everybody kind of
Waits and see with Biden Biden's always
said I'm running but fate may get in the
way I've noticed this year he doesn't
have it he didn't have it before but
this year he really doesn't have it I
haven't seen him smile this wide since
he went to Belfast he hasn't looked this
alive ever he touches down and all of a
sudden the guy all of a sudden has a
pulse but then he gets back to this
country and he hangs out with the Easter
Bunny and Al Roker it makes no sense it
is a fraud his presidency and the press
is in bed with Joe Biden perpetuating
this fraud we say we have a free press
we don't they're swallowed a gag ball
they're the ones that threw the gag ball
down their own throats you don't ask the
president about the former president
being indicted you know what they asked
him before he took off to Ireland who
are you bringing to Ireland
so you can't pretend like you want to
know what the president thinks and then
when you get a shot at the president ask
him who he's bringing and you know who
he's bringing Hunter this is a family
trip and he's never had to answer about
the laptop he's never had to answer
about lying about his family taking
money from China he hasn't ever answered
why he popped a 20 balloon with a two
million dollar missile right he hasn't
been asked about the cartels he hasn't
been asked about Jack and that's not
fair to the American people what about
Jack
you know just a correction uh it's uh
ball gag not gag ball thank you Greg
okay we just because I don't want to get
the letters from our uh we have a large
s m uh demographic history is that what
that represents if that's the only
mistake I'm gonna make today I'll take
it oh it's a bit you know a good day it
can it can be a big mistake in certain
places but Greg knows it is also very
suspicious all right hey Sean Hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to Fox
News YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else